what emerged is a genuine expression
from vast groups of people who do not
have that public voice as a result we
have something very very passionate
which i think is so valuable my name is
richie mehta and i directed film called
india in a day and that film is
documentary crowd-sourced where we asked
people all over India to shoot footage
of their lives using their own camera
phones whatever cameras could they could
get a hold of it submitted that footage
by Google we took that made a
feature-length documentary tracking one
day in India from midnight to midnight
so that was the brief but we'd throw out
a couple of questions if people needed
it you know what do you love what do you
hope for what do you fear things like
that just to get people thinking if they
needed it most people didn't but the
idea being that this type of film is
basically a tapestry so the whole film
has been constructed that way so that's
why it was the idea was it was more
labor for our team to go through
everything but but the treasure was just
shoot anything and we'll create that
over 16,000 clips were submitted but
that's the number i know for sure and I
clip can range from two seconds two to
three hours so there was a lot to go
through in that way we had a whole team
of people that would kind of watch
everything and rate that footage you
know the goal post keep changing because
we're not actually sure what we're
looking for we just know there's
something fascinating when we finally
see it oh and I think there were some
very strong themes and ideas emerging as
well as entertaining kind of just
glimpses in people's lives and that
became the genesis of final film again
well sometimes you pick up a thread and
be like this is something interesting
and it really need to lead you nowhere
and other times you find a little thing
inside this is super special in we
started to see the bigger stories
emerging because we were given this and
I we kind of looked at it and said okay
audiences are going to come into this
knowing that everything they're going to
see is real every scrap of footage is
honest and genuine and so you you don't
look at it as a normal feature film
you're not looking for performance
you're not looking for that type of
nuance
you assume that there's a purity of
messaging which we take hopefully take
into account when we consume a film like
this because i think that the ideas are
so big and so vast and so self
reflective i hope people come out
questioning their preconceived notions
about a country like india about a place
like the other I think Indians will be
surprised because its diverse country as
we say in the film people oftentimes
people don't understand each other so
many languages and cultures the fact
that I speak Hindi and Punjabi and I
don't understand half of the Indian
languages in the film I think it's
amazing there's nobody in the world that
can watch this film and understand
everything it says without subtitles
what I think is wonderful so I think
people are going to be surprised I think
I hope they're delighted by what they
see because there's a there's a delight
factor in it imagine we had that from 50
years ago just a day in the life
watching it you know 24 hours unfold we
I mean sociologists will be studying it
and I'm not going to be so you know so
bold as to say people will be studying
in the 50 years from now at the same
time I think we presented it in such a
manner that it makes it fascinating to
consume now
[Music]